we saw in the case of former Yugoslavia
that at least some degree the US
government tried to leave religion out
of its analysis answer to minimize the
role that my term might be playing in
the situation with Sri Lanka how does
how does the way the you at the
international community how should the
international community approach the
issue of religion in this in the role
that might might or might not be playing
in violence there does just talking
about Sri Lanka in religious terms just
inflamed divisions that that might
actually betters being used a certain
way and it when it's really about the
economic and individual interest that
you spoke about or is it leaving out a
central element so that if that is
really motivating a lot of people and
it's important to understand hmm if you
tear up the first part of a question the
you know the international community is
a is one of those words in Sri Lanka
that is also sort of classified along
with all foreign things you are like
along with Kentucky Fried Chicken so
they are all you know so if if there is
going to be any productive action on the
part of the international community it
has to be approached in I mean you have
to approach it in a very very sensitive
very kind of disguised manner it could
be some indirect support for example to
encourage the I have been advocating
personally no figures comparable to you
know this great figures not not mental a
stretcher but you know small-scale
Mandela's you can find in
in Sri Lanka so if the international
community the Americans for example can
encourage some of these people and say
why don't you you know do this do that
and maybe they can even guide you some
guy dancing in and about what exactly
might be according to their own
experience might be might be effective
so if if there is any international
input I think it has to be in some sort
of way you know some sort of nuanced way
I'm sorry i forgot the second part of
question how did you look at this your
religion specifically Oh like well
they're not emphasizing that it's
looking at it in religious terms is just
inflaming tensions that are you know
based on divisions that are being used
instead of what the violence is really
about or whether or not they whether or
not the international community should
talk about things in religious terms
because that's what's motivating people
no i'm still unclear about the question
because are you saying that since real
motivation for violence is not religious
but economic and so on and therefore the
international community should do
something about that they said said what
you ask should they should they leave
religion in or out of their analyses I
think they should keep religion in D
analysis because again the this brings
up a very important question which I had
no time to raise which is what do we
mean by religion actually now when we
talk for example talk about Buddhism as
if it is one thing as not the case at
all there are not only different
Buddhism's in different parts of the
world but with in Sri Lanka is very
clear that the paper you read Tom Byers
is making a distinction between between
this kind of kind of paradigm that I
talked about these particular myths
around what he calls political Buddhism
and and this is although the term
political Buddhism has been used to
describe this recent things but in fact
it is quite old and now in the morning
up in my discussion with Lisa we go to
this example of King going back to the
2nd century where he his problems that
is about to wage war on the Tamils and
he says this voice is not for my surface
is I am wedging it not for my glory but
4242 for the sake of Buddhism and and
and I remarked that in this election
serious and this just sound familiar to
you because what the king is saying is
that it's my religion first me second
you know but so this has been there for
a long time so and Tamba also makes a
distinction between what he calls for
today he uses the moral principle and
cultural possession now Buddhism
presumably in the Buddhist on original
sin she is a moral principle but in fact
it has been converted into a cultural
position where the possession of it is
becomes part of your identity and
something to flaunt about and to
proclaim to the world that you are the
custodians of this great noble doctrine
but you do not do anything with it you
just use it and in fact use it in in in
a responsible ways to simply to oppress
other people and in the pro in the sense
of making part of your oppressive
identity and so Buddhism I mean when you
talk about religion therefore in you
have to obviously talk about the
possibilities of using the moral
principle as as possibly
you know some instrument of change in
the situation and to do that again I
think what is important is you have to
you have to find an effective link and
that is again I think it was an is what
Peter was saying because there is no
sense in having having a noble idea
there must be some effective method of
translating that into action to
effective social action and this is a
great insight of Max Weber's Protestant
ethic and the spirit of capitalism where
it is not not the case that he said you
know Protestantism causes capitalism he
he laid out a series of intervening
variables which which illustrate clearly
how this what he called you know how the
but it is not the Calvin never not the
Lutheran but the Calvinistic Reformation
the question of predestination and how
it led to a vertical the inner isolation
of the individual and then the search
for in and after Calvin told his
questioners that there is no way to know
whether you are one of the Damned to one
of the saved and and I mean when he was
breast is only answer was that is really
no way of knowing but the only you can
have some sort of inkling of it if you
feel a sense of total dedication in work
when you do in other when you work in
your mundane employment if you feel
nothing but the sense that you are
working the glory of God then you that's
an inkling that you are one is the same
so naturally everybody wanted to have
that feeling you keep work working and
working and working and of course he
also advocated setas ism that means that
you you you were can produce but you do
not consume and the arithmetic is very
very clear because it is when you add
the net and own subject you have what is
called the accumulation of capital so
there is a capitalism so so you have an
effective series you know so you must
you cannot just simply have a noble idea
and then expect it to work but you won't
find some mechanism
and and I and I think both of we are
suggesting as a possibility of actual
individuals like little Mandela's if you
can find little man they loss and you
know in sort of post a mirror in there
and then see whether we can do some
conspiracy to you know do this